bien mon petit garçon vient à l'on vient
de faire pipi mais tu feras pas tu vas
tu faire pipi bien mon petit gars au hip
hop
lp
comment t'appelles tu es toi
est ce que tes parents sont venus avec
toi non viens viens t'asseoir sur mes
genoux vont bien
est ce que t'as pas forcer un peu sur le
goûter
oui tu aimes bien le cerceau un bon oui
le regard dans tes jambes c'est ce que
je pensais tout à l'heure
c'est pas mon cerveau et ma ceinture
et qu'est ce que tu vas nous chanter
d'abord quel est ton prénom un tel est
ton prénom valérie
et qu'est ce que tu chantes un sens oui
qu'est-ce qu'il a fait la chanson une
chanson l'ip tutu et propre mon petit
non c'est trop tard
alem le poser une question avant qui est
fait est fait
c'est pas grave on reconnaît ses amis
dans le besoin
ah le vilain bambins la question et fut
rebâtie savez comme moi je chante une
chanson oh tu crois que c'est la peine
après l'amour quand nos corps se détend
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]